ومعنا من غلاف غزه مراسله الجزيره نجوان
سمري نجوان تفاصيل اكثر حول هذا القصف من
طرف القسام لموقع كيسوفيم العسكري في غلاف
غزه نعم بالفعل كانت في الساعه الاخيره
الماضيه قد دوت صافرات الانذار في عدد من
البلدات والمواقع في منطقه غلاف غزه لكن
بحسب ما اعلن من الجانب الاسرائيلي فقد تم
اعتراض
اي القضائ الصاروخيه ولم تسقط ولم تؤدي
الى اضرار او اصابات وفقا للاعلان من
الجانب الاسرائيلي لكن نقول بان في الايام
الاخيره الماضيه عادت لتدو بكثافه اكبر
ربما صافرات الانذار في هذه المناطق
الليله الماضيه دوت صافرات الانذار في
مواقع عده تحديدا في منطقه ناح العوز ولكن
ايضا في ساعات المساء و ايه من الواضح بان
ال قدره المقاومه الفلسطينيه على توجيه
مثل هذه القضائ الصاروخيه والصواريخ
باتجاه البلدات الحدوديه في منطقه غلاف
غزه مستمره وهو ربما ما يقلق من جهه
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه ويربك الجيش
الاسرائيلي ايضا لكن
بالاساس يؤدي الى مزيد من الغضب تحديدا
لدى سكان هذه المناطق بعد الاعلان في
الاونه الاخيره عن نيه الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه تحديدا وزاره الدفاع وعلى
راسها يوف جلنت وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بالبدء باعاده سكان هذه المناطق الذين
يصرون على انهم لن يعودوا الى هذه المناطق
قبل التاكد من انه لن تكون هناك صافرات
انذار ولن يكون هناك اطلاق للصواريخ
للصواريخ لا سما وانه قبل يومين وصلت هذه
الصواريخ الى منطقه النقب الغربي وسقطت
وادت الى اضرار بالغه في مدينه نيتي فوت
الواقعه على بعد 20 ك مت من قطاع غزه
وبالتالي هذا يعيد مجددا هذا النقاش بين
سكان هذه المناطق وبين المؤسسه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه عن جدوى عودتهم في مثل هذه
المرحله في الوقت الذي تريد ايضا الاجهزه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه والمؤسسه الامنيه
والعسكريه اعاده السكان كواحده من الصور
للنصر التي تبحث عنها اسرائيل في هذه
المرحله بانها تمكنت من اعاده السكان الى
هنا لكن سهام دعين اشير الى اننا من
المناطق الشماليه التي بدانا نرصد فيها
انخفاض
لوتيربرونين
توقف صوت القصف يعني وصلنا قبل قليل
والقذف المدفعي يكاد لا يتوقف على الاطلاق
من موا وا واقع مختلفه على هذه المناطق
التي تقابل المنطقه الوسطى في قطاع غزه
وايضا نحن يعني على مقربه كذلك من المناطق
التي تقابل منطقه خان يونس وبالتالي هنا
الاصوات مختلفه كليا عما كنا رصدناه في
ساعات الصباح ويوم امس ايضا في المناطق
الشماليه اصوات للقصف المدفعي وتحليق ايضا
للطائرات الحربيه لا يتوقف في هذه المناطق
ومن الواضح ان هنا وتيره القصف متواصله
ومستمره على مواقع عده وهذا تماما ربما ما
يتحدث عنه الزملاء من جهه في مدينه غزه
وكذلك ياتي على ذكره الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي في بياناته بان ال ال القتال
هنا في هذه المناطق تحديدا وعمليات الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما زالت ب متواصله بكثافتها
الاولى وعلى عكس ما يحدث في المناطق
الشماليه التي يتحدث الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي بانها عمليات محدوده ومحدده
الاهداف لكن رغم ذلك يعني راينا في بيانه
الصباحي هذا اليوم الناطق العسكري تحدث عن
ان هناك كانت اشتباكات يوم امس قتل فيها
عدد من المسلحين الفلسطينيين او من
المقاومين الفلسطينيين في اشتباكات وقعت
تحديدا في المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
وبالتالي ربما هو وفقا للتسميات التي
حددها الج اليش الاسرائيلي بان هناك مناطق
انتقلت فيها الحرب لمراحل مختلفه بينما
تواصل مرحله القتال الواسع في المناطق
الوسطى والمناطق الجنوبيه الا انه من
الواضح ايضا بانه يقوم بتنفيذ عمليات
مختلفه ايضا في الشمال وهي تكون بالعاده
رد على عمليات المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهو ما
يؤكد بالتالي ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما
زالت تنشط في المناطق الشماليه يوم امس
سمعنا وزير الدفا الفاع الاسرائيلي يتحدث
بانه سيكون من الصعب القضاء على ما يصفه
بجيوب المقاومه وهذا تماما ما بدا في
الاونه الاخيره الاعلام الاسرائيلي يتحدث
عنه من فكره القضاء كليا على حركه حماس في
قطاع غزه يتم يعني تغيير المصطلحات تباعا
بعد ان قالوا بانهم قاموا بتفكيك الاطر
العسكريه لحركه حماس تحديدا والفصائل
الفلسطينيه في المناطق الشماليه الان نسمع
ان هناك بعض الجيوب على شكل افراد
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه تتحرك في المناطق
الشماليه وسيكون من الصعب القضاء عليها
هذه تصريحات لافته ايضا ضمن التراجع تباعا
عن ما تم التصريح به بدايه هذه الحرب من
اهداف فضفاضه حددها السياسيون تحديدا وعلى
راسهم رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو بان
الهدف من هذه الحرب القضاء على حركه حماس
كليا كذلك يعني ايه كانت صحيفه هارت يوم
امس ق قد قالت بان هناك رصد لدى الاجهزه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه
و وايضا لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي
بعوده حركات المقاومه حركه حماس الى
المنطقه الشماليه لتنشط بشكل او باخر من
اجل اعاده تاهيل كتائبها العسكريه وايضا
تعيين قاده جدد بدل الذين قام الجيش
الاسرائيلي باغتياله في الاونه الاخيره
وهذا فقط يؤكد على ان حركات المقاومه
مستمره بانشطه العسكريه والسطو ايضا سهام
نجو سمري مراسله الجزيره كنت معنا من غلاف
غزه شكرا لك